so to run the pipeline go down here to
amplicon16s 18s
and here let us set up the pipeline
so first of all
you can use different types of databases
why is this important
silva is a good database to use in a lot
of cases when people use environmental
samples from soil and
water
you might want to refer to the green
genes database that might have better
annotation for those types of sequences
but for the local ones that means that
it's a database that is uploaded on the
server and we can select the silver
database
the second thing is we have parent or
single end and the only option for data2
is parent it's built for
pair and reads and here we have to
select fastq
then we click on file upload
and here we need to
use the url bulk upload option
to use the svls
okay so you can decide which one you
want to use the
small one
which is just fecal
or the big one which is both fecal and
sql
okay that one has twice as many samples
and then you have to upload the
supplementary text file so this is going
to be used for annotation so you have to
remember what are
the names in your table
so here the name is library name okay so
you're gonna just gotta remember how you
exactly spell that
and submit
and now i'll build the pipeline and i'll
explain what each step does so we start
we can skip pre-processing in this case
we will do quality control based on qc
filtering so what this does is looks for
specific lengths of the forward and the
backward read files
and allows for certain errors within
those
if your settings are incorrect for
example if the length of your read is
150 and you put 250 the whole pipeline
will then fail
okay so then why are we looking for
replication count
okay
replication count means that we are
looking for pcr amplified
continuous repeats of the same sequence
are going to be eliminated they don't
provide any new information because
remember this is not a quantitative
technique it's a technique to look at
diversity and not to quantify how much
of each type of
taxonomic classification we have
okay then we merge the pairs
so here we again have some settings
the pairs of reads have to be merged so
that they
are considered to be coming from the
same biological sequence so there's too
much of a spread between them
you want to eliminate them
then from these reads we build consensus
clusters or otus operational taxonomic
units
the goal of this procedure is to
eliminate technical
issues
that come from the different types of
issues like pcr amplification bad
quality pair and reads and in this case
chemeric reads chimeric reads are reads
that look like a single read but they
actually come from two different
biological
pieces of dna
and so here those are selected and
eliminated from our data
and finally the taxonomy is assigned for
each otu
now once you have those
taxonomic classes
assigned to otu's you can ask the
question how are these related so if
they are closely related
or farther apart
it makes sense to analyze
samples that have a diversity
of microorganisms that have
very different
evolutionary backgrounds as something
different as when we have something that
are only closely related types of
microorganisms so that's why this part
is being done and here we can select two
different tree methods we can just keep
it at
nearest joint name so engine
now the filo seek
is where we visualize the results just
like we did last time manually this is
going to be done in an automated way and
then we'll take a look at how to do this
in r so here we can choose taxonomic
level why don't we choose the lowest
level with greatest definition of what
we might expect to find in our
biological sample so why not go for
family or species one consideration
could be that you know we'll find just
too much diversity to interpret
the reason is actually because in some
cases
we don't have a good annotation so the
lower we go in the taxonomic
classification
the less is known
like for example if we see a
microorganism and it has a 16s ribosomal
rna we know it's a bacteria it's not
anything else
so kingdom we know to recognize very
well but the lower we go in the
taxonomic classification the less we're
able to identify these databases are
just not rich enough because the
diversity of microorganisms as we
already saw in our last session is so
huge so typically people go
genus order or above
okay so phylum is a good way to
summarize the data
class we can get greater definition but
it becomes confusing starts getting a
lot of information order right more
specific etc so let's keep it
at class
now here is the next uh
parameter mean abundance
there are going to be some old to use
that have a lot of
uh members present
and so for example if we have the phylum
selected we know that hundreds is a good
definition we can change this and maybe
put it at 50 to see what happens
because we selected class
now color remember we have this
additional column called library name
and later on we can look at how we can
include other factors
so but this is how we can assign colors
and shapes to individual samples based
on
in this case library name
and then ordination method so
just like we use principal component
analysis to study variation between
samples using continuous data this data
because it's organized by operational
taxonomic units is going to be sparse
so it's going to have a lot of gaps and
because it has a lot of gaps
non-dime non-metric space is better
for this kind of an analysis so you can
choose typically use people use
non-metric dimensionality reduction
techniques like nmds or pcoa
okay and then you can click on save
and click on end
okay it will probably take anywhere
between 10 and 15 minutes but not a long
time so let's go to download pipeline
output files in the pipeline that i
gave right so
please open this pipeline together with
me so you can take a look at the results
okay so first of all let's take a look
at this abundance
table
okay this abundance table
tells us how much of each otu
was found in each one of our samples
remember the first three
are
i think uh ciao the second three are
high fat diet
okay
so with this information we can't do a
lot but we can do something like
you know nmds or pcoa now what do i mean
by sparse data first of all that means
that we have a lot of zeros
right so there's a lot of o to use that
have zero in one category and some
number in another category but also look
at the numbers they're not continuous we
go from 55 to 211 to 117 right so these
are not continuous numbers okay
what's the second one the second one
tells us the error plots for how the
reads were selected
and there are two criteria for how the
reads were selected first of all
expected
substitutions
and
also
there is going to be a quality profile
for the forward and the back reads so
you can see that the quality of the
forward
direction reads
is
greater than the ones for the other
direction right so you can see the score
of quality here on the y
and
here's the position of each read so you
can see that it
especially here you can see that it
falls right here right right about 270
which is what we specify
now the other thing is that you can
notice here how many total reads we have
we have over a hundred thousand reads in
each one
how many oh to use 300 right so from a
hundred thousand
this was grouped into operational
taxonomic units
and only 300 are left now this is going
to be very useful because when we think
of a phylogenetic analysis between
hundreds of thousands of sequences
that's not useful
but between 300 this is somewhat
meaningful okay and it's meaningful
because now we can study diversity
so here we have the phylogenetic tree
and we also have let's now take a look
at
phyloclasts
okay so for the phylloc plus
we have some summary
of what was actually okay what does it
mean
that we have a zero in the table so
imagine you're looking for
a bacteria that does not exist in that
particular sample right that
means you will have zero
in your table
okay so here we have the same data that
we saw in the abundance
but instead of the otus we have them
organized classified by phyla
so the phyla that we have as the most
dominant is bacterial dts and
fermicutes and then we have these
smaller proportions down here at the
bottom
so
the remember we use the threshold
100 or 50
and we can see the top abundance so here
we have the top abundant otus
and here we have the rest right so here
you can see abundance goes between 100
which was our threshold to 500 and here
are the rest 0.025 to 0.1
so now we can kind of
think of
in terms of the most dominant
classes that we are looking at
how are they different between the two
conditions that we have ciao
and high fat diet for example we can see
that otu 7
4 and 5
are only at 15
are only present in high fat diet
as opposed to chow right we can see for
example that 13 12 and 14 are specific
to
chao
and in some cases we see this
interesting composition otu 16 has less
in ciao and more in
high fat diet right so this is based on
otu
now how can this data be summarized to
tell us what is the overall difference
between these samples
and here we have two metrics
first is the alpha diversity metric so
the alpha diversity metric tells us
about composition within each sample
and this number right here the y
represents approximately you can kind of
say this is how many individual species
do we have right
so remember
if you can kind of think of otus as
distinct individual
groups of microbes
you can say that this is a number of how
many
of different kinds
are present in each sample it's a little
bit more complicated than that we have
two different metrics to measure this
but you can see that this particular
metric tells us that right so here we
have a group these are fairly consistent
these are
the chao samples and these are the bkf
sorry these are the high fat diet and
there's quite a lot of variation in
those
but we have two contradicting kind of
results here one says that it's lower
diversity another one says that it's
higher diversity right and so the
conclusion from this is we probably
should include a little bit more samples
which is why we gave you the second
table to try and run that analysis again
how can we plot these graphs in your
software so right after i'm done with
explaining what this means we will go to
r and you will plot all of these in r
that um once you've got the data
processed you can use filoc and r to
plot these
um there
okay
and the second measure is beta diversity
right and so beta diversity tells us
what's the difference between samples so
here you have two groups of samples and
you have a good separation between them
in this non-metric space and so this
diversity
shows us that indeed there's a good
separation between the ciao and high fat
diet it is less related to by which
because
this actually tells us language right
and so here you have these weights come
in because
the difference the fact that otu 7 is
high abundance which means it's
important
and in the phylogenetic tree it's so
distant from the rest it means it's
something unique that we should probably
give more weight to
as opposed to for example we have these
three guys right here and there's some
difference in abundance between them as
well and then these two right but
they're fairly close together
evolutionary speaking and so that maybe
has less of a significance for us in
terms of how we look at this information